[Music]
how sick would you get if you never took
your contacts out you can probably
imagine the discomfort that would come
from leaving them in four days but what
about weeks or months or even years
how much would you damage your vision
could you lose your eyes and why might
it cause you to have diarrhea this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you never took your contacts out
contact lenses stay on your eyes by
sticking to the thin layer of tear fluid
found on the surface of the eye this
fluid is produced every time you blink
and it's responsible for washing away
any dirt that might become stuck to a
lens if you were to wear your contact
lenses while you sleep
there'd be no blinking going on to keep
things clean bacteria would start to
build up on the lens and you'd wake up
with stinging red eyes and that's just
after day one how much worse would
things get the struggle to remember to
take out and clean your contacts every
night is more common than you might
think in the United States alone
approximately 30 to 45 million people
wear contact lenses most people wear
them to improve their vision some people
wear them to change their eye color and
some wear them for protection from
ultraviolet rays but no matter why you
wear them you still have to clean and
disinfect them on a regular basis and
that's where the danger would come in to
never taking your contacts out it's not
the foreign object on your eye that
would cause you the most problems it's
what would be growing on that object if
you never cleaned your contacts then
protein deposits allergens and
microorganisms would buildup on the lens
leading to blurred vision is a bacterial
building up on your eye could lead to
something called keratitis that's an
infection of the dome-shaped window of
the eye known as the cornea in severe
cases keratitis can lead to corneal
scarring vision loss and complete
blindness and even if you're one of the
lucky cases you'd still be suffering
from a sensitivity to light redness of
the eyes tearing and various degrees of
pain and discomfort
once symptoms started to appear
there'd be no turning back unless you
remove your contacts every day would be
worse than the day before
you'd constantly be rubbing your red
squinted eyes suffering from headaches
and streams of uncontrollable tears
would be gushing down your cheeks it's
safe to say that anyone who kept their
contacts in all the time would be pretty
irritable oh and some of them could be
pooping the pants too but more on that
in a second with all the chaos taking
place in your eyes you wouldn't be able
to drive play sports or read even your
TV and computer screens would just be a
big blur of colors
sure you could just keep treating your
eye infections with antibiotics but that
would have its own set of problems since
prolonged exposure to antibiotics can
result in antibiotic resistance the
antibiotics could also disrupt the
natural balance of good and bad bacteria
in your body the good bacteria that help
with our digestion could be obliterated
leaving the bad bacteria to take over
our intestines
if this happens you're going to need to
use your blurred vision to find a toilet
quickly because it usually results in
extreme diarrhea so maybe you should
just follow the instructions on your
contacts and clean them regularly you
don't want to screw up the one pair of
eyes that you've got unless you could
just grow new ones but that's a topic
for another what if
[Music]